los jóvenes han vuelto a salir a la
calle y a la luz del día y es que hoy
Estaba convocada una gran huelga que
habían aceptado
110 universidades y centros educativos
en todo el país No solamente enteraron
donde se veía como los estudiantes de
las grandes universidades salían esta
mañana a protestar Incluso se vio como
las autoridades llegaron a disparar
gases lacrimógenos en el centro de la
ciudad donde está la universidad de
Teherán que históricamente ha sido el
centro educativo que ha liderado esas
grandes protestas en Irán no solamente
contra la República islámica sino
también cuando se hizo la revolución de
1979 pero también se extienden a otras
ciudades del país incluso a mashup que
es la ciudad religiosa del país que está
liderada por el gran ayatola tal vez el
más radical del país y que es el suegro
del presidente Ibrahim raicides
muy bien esos videos se han ido
difundiendo a lo largo del día en Irán y
es interesante porque la semana pasada
hubo dos días de fiesta lo que hizo que
las universidades estuvieran cerradas
pero hoy vuelve a reactivarse la vida no
solamente a nivel universitario sino
también en los Colegios del país y eso
también sucede cuando se dan dos grandes
enfrentamientos en dos grandes
provincias fronterizas unan si están
valuche Están en la capital sajerán se
han visto grandes enfrentamientos en las
últimas horas y en el kurdistán iraní de
donde era maxa mini hay una gran huelga
donde tiene la mayoría del comercio
cerrado